التوتر العسكري بين تايوان والصين يتفاقم
وسط مخاوف من سيناريوهات عده لاحتماليه
غزو الصين لتايوان هل سيتم عبر حصار مشدد
ام هجوم كاسه هذا هو السؤال الاساسي اليوم
في تقرير لصحيفه التايمز البريطانيه يشير
الى ان مثل هذا التحرك العسكري لبكين له
تداعيات ابعد من الجزيره قد تجتذب الى
صراع قوى عظمى او حتى لسيناريو اسوا اي
حرب نوويه لكن يبقى السيناريو المنتظر هل
تغزو بكين بالفعل ام لا وفقا لمحللين
عسكريين مشاهدينا فان سيناريو الغزو امر
متوقع لكنه سيكون من المستحيل اطلاق الغزو
على حين غره او على بفجاه طبعا حيث
سيستغرق الصين وستستغرق الصين اسابيع
لتتجمع في الموانئ الصينيه على مراه ومسمع
من اقمار التجسس الغربيه
الحصار يمكن ان يبدا ببطء وبشكل خفيف دون
ان يلاحظ احد وقد يمتد لشهور او سنوات
يمكن كذلك ان يبدا حصار تايوان بتدريبات
عسكريه طبعا على غرار التي تم اجراءها على
مدى اشهر بقطع حركه المرور الجويه
والبحريه والبريه للجزيره كما اصبح معلوما
مع عمليات تفتيش صينيه الزانيه صحيفه
الفرنسيه اشارت الى سيناريو اخر يتضمن
هجوما صينيا يستهدف الجزر التايوانيه
الاقرب للبر الرئيسي للصين لكن صعوبه هذا
السيناريو تتمثل في الهبوط في تايوان
نفسها خاصه مع انظمه دفاع متطوره قدمتها
الولايات المتحده للاخيره الى جانب
استراتيجيه بكين العسكريه نحو حصار طويل
الامد تتعمد الصين استخدام حرب نفسيه تهدف
طبعا لاحباط عزيمه سكان تايوان على المدى
الطويل وهي لاستراتيجيه التي تفضلها بكين
حسب العديد من الخبراء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات